quant à ta dah attention demain
abattement respectable du cirque à
pignan ne ratez pas l'occasion et
consolidé on est à vierzon sur toute la
semaine jusqu'à dimanche soir et
on repart à 10 pour continuer notre
l'année dernière on a fait la loire à
vélo et la chine ont sur mur jusqu'à
orléans
tous les ans on plane sur les
différences une caravane d'une
demi-douzaine de roulottes tirées par
des chevaux dans les rues de vierzon
c'est le cirque bidon en tournée pendant
quatre mois dans le berry de villes en
villages
il propose un spectacle sans paillettes
et sans artifice avec une douzaine
d'artistes polyvalent c'est pas du
cirque traditionnel du tout c'est pas
non plus du cirque ce qu'on appelle
nouveaux circoncis renseigner on a un
style style bidon
créé il y à une quarantaine d'années par
françois rollin' un artiste anar
autodidacte des années 60 la compagnie
revient en fait aux fondamentaux du
cirque comme à l'époque des troubadours
[Musique]
j'ai d'abord fait l'expérience des jeux
la roue avec les foules et après on a
fait un plaisir qui a duré deux ans qui
appelait à la virtus et en soirée sur
vidéo donc ça fait déjà 25 ans tu seras
mon idée de faire un moteur des
spectacles tout doucement donc vraiment
là où vivent les gens et beaucoup de
gens qui viennent me voir alors il
devrait permettre à spa le ciel compta
les artistes car les pieds sous la table
quand on participe à tout le cirque
la vaisselle au tour de vaisselle chacun
s'occupe d'un cheval on a des roulottes
six ans nino par deux sur les roulottes
pour les trajets roulotte
du coup chacun songe pas à la préparer
et de mettre les cuire la plage pour moi
la route c'est un peu c'est un peu
l'essence du cirque bidon parce que le
contact avec les chevaux c'est un truc
super important dans cette aventure en
vérité donc les routes les changement
d'endroit même les roues de camions
parfois parce que tu arrives dans un
nouveau village parce que tu découvres à
nouveau quelque chose parce que c'est
super chouette ce que nous on préfère je
pense c'est la vie d'avant-hier quoi
quand tu es ici tu réfléchis pas à vous
après on commence à boire à manger
dans les tec attendant on travaille la
fête à cannes après il faut qu'elle le
demande on verra un minuit
j'ai le plein de métiers chauffeur
routier mécanicien ferrailleurs soudeur
je m'occupe de toute la technique des
véhicules un petit peu les animaux est
un peu de tout en général c'est ma
septième année c'est un seul but dont je
joue la patronne du siècle madame teresa
et le spectacle je suis pour garder la
tradition c'est à dire un le cpeq il
existe sans chapiteau avec le voyage les
roulottes et donc j'ai à faire à mes
gamins qui eux voudraient plus confort
de modernité
c'est vrai qu'au début ça me semblait
comme une parenthèse mais petit à petit
c'est la troisième année que je viens
j'ai l'impression que fait ma vraie vie
c'est plutôt ici c'est comme si j'avais
toujours attendue de vivre ce genre de
choses parfois ça mais c'est quoi ça
sert la poisson
le thème de ce spectacle conçu par
françois rollin' dit françois bidon et
un comédien s'intitule il fera bout ce
soir où de nombreuses disciplines
s'entremêlent avec poésie danse musique
théâtre chant acrobaties
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sap a déjà pas des chapiteaux pas du
tout nouveau spectacle sur la technique
sur les performances ou c'est beaucoup
plus sûr le rêve sur le coguic sur
surprendre les gens c'est tout
tout à fait notre démarche le spectacle
cette année on allait au 101e alors mis
les roues des as doit que ça tourne bien
avec les gens ça se passe bien sa place
et en plus il par ici on est dans une
région connue on est près de chez moi
et là on dirait bon chablis qui répond
bien que j'aie un camion tout le temps
et voir donc pas bien toujours aussi
magique et et au sénat mais les enfants
adorent times bon bah oui parce que
c'est du vrai ça c'est du vrai cirque il
n'y a pas de chapiteau pas police et
chaleureuse
on est dedans avoue jean toutes les
sensations n'étaient pas de la piste ça
c'est très sympathique et un contact
avec les artistes qui est beaucoup plus
proche
emporté par la foule à tous ses lancers
qui dans une folle farandole mots de
marc est fondée et papa sow n'avait pas
d'accord raison à ses cendres
les retombées tolosa mise en oeuvre est
mieux là lé feu
elle est très sage aimait le vif et la
pâte légère elle va tenter encore une
fois ce soir son périlleux numéro sur la
corde raide musique est là quelle grâce
au cours de ses voyages elle a eu deux
filles bien élevées en plein air voici
tout d'abord l'aîné midi presqu'aussitôt
de sa soeur qu'à quelques têtes et
quelques cadeaux des fêtes sa soeur mais
[Rires]
dans son périple de quatre mois à
travers le berry françois rollin' trouve
toujours le temps de faire les brocantes
l'occasion de chiner et de croiser des
spectateurs de la veille à nous et ça va
aller
hier on était complet à bien le son est
offert en corse après midi à son coeur
[Musique]
je cherche des vieux bouquins et même
des trucs pour le cir les accessoires
d'éveil paul effa ya des trucs pour les
chevaux entre les spectacles
la vie reprend son cours chaque artiste
dispose d'une caravane qui lui sert à la
fois du gîte et de loges pour répéter
son numéro c'est une lettre qui
s'appelle la casquette c'est pas une de
plus vieille des cirques
mais elle est quand même là une des plus
grandes et plus lumineux lumineux la
sueur je profite de l'espace pour
géoglyphes une langue là je me prends
pas au couple a dû jongler au contact
des murs des contacts avec la balle tout
le temps
[Musique]
on passe la moitié de notre temps dehors
un petit peu du coup on reste bon on
reste à l'intérieur souvent elles m'ont
fait à manger ont recoupé chaussettes
pour moi c'est quand même assez dur ce
que j'avais jamais été en couple
longtemps alors là on travaille en
famille sur dans un tout petit espace là
on est vraiment mais vraiment sur
l'autre pendant six mois pas évident
mais ça va quand même mais ça va me
intérêts de certains des 28 mois
ensemble effectivement on mange tous les
gérants sont bons c'est arrivé
quelquefois que certaines personnes se
croyait fait pour ce genre de vie puis
au bout de deux mois ça ça serait ça
n'allait pas mais où c'est normalement
on sait qu'on s'engage pour six mois
donc même s'il ya des petites la panne
n'est pas forcément toujours sur la même
longueur d'onde
voilà on fait en sorte que ça aille bien
pour qui l'amour
je check d'harmoniser le plus possible
il ya des règles mais y en a qui sont
très bons sur la piste pour le spectacle
mais qui ne sont pas du tout bon parfait
pour la vie en groupe ça c'est important
c'est au moins la moitié quoi donc il
faut quelqu'un qui soit bon sur l'api
c'est bon pour la vie en groupe sinon
sinon c'est l'enfer moi c'est pas
vraiment seulement sur le côté technique
par un morceau de jonglage ou n'importe
quoi à l'acrobatie
mais il faut qu'il ya un petit il faut
faire un petit côté comme moi j'appelle
à petit côté bidon et c'est pas
forcément le meilleur si tu veux mais il
faut qu'ils aient un côté un peu qui y
va sur la qui va bien pour moi à mes
yeux un peu sur la dérision même sur le
raté sur la dérision mais qu'ils soient
bien bien les pieds sur terre bien sûr
les pieds sur la scène
je
pendant le spectacle
lorsqu'il n'est plus à la caisse
philippe prépare le repas cuisinier de
métier sa route a croisé il ya un an
celle du cirque bidon
ici c'est pas comme si j'étais cuisinier
j'ai pas de pression je peux faire une
tarte chocolat banane poivrons et
amendes si j'ai envie d'essayer un truc
je peux tout faire après c'est le moment
où on se rassemble dans la journée quoi
c'est le moment où on se retrouve à
table on discute de ce qui va de ce
qu'il va pas c'est chouette d'être à
cette place là parce que eh bah parce
que je sais pas je me sens au centre
d'un truc qui rassemble les gens nous
amène les légumes de leur jardin
un pâté qu'ils ont fait une bouteille de
vin quand on est à sancerre et va on
nous emmène du sancerre les derniers
jours soit pour des montants ont fait un
pique nique
parce qu'on m'a déjà dit montella tout
ça donc calorifique noire de monde le
cirque
[Musique]
ça fait au moins cinq six ans pour être
même tarif pour qu'elle soit accessible
à tout le monde j'ai fait presque toute
ma vie sans subvention on y arrivait
mais disons que c'est comme un moment
qu'on est un peu aidé c'est quand même
plus confortable le stress que plus on
était surtout pour le matériel avant
j'avais du matériel pourri des trucs à
la limite pas trop en a une sur la route
et tous que maintenant on a pu remettre
tout ça à neuf et là on est plus
tranquille quoi c'est surtout pour ça
quoi comme chaque année le cirque bidon
prend ses quartiers d'hiver à pic ou
landes en indre près du village de
jacques tati ils auront parcouru près de
700 km de juin à septembre à travers le
loir et cher l'indre le cher et la
nièvre est proposé leur spectacle dans
une trentaine de communes pour les
artistes de ce cirque pas tous les
autres c'est la fin du voyage le temps
d'écrire et de mettre au point le
prochain spectacle
et pourquoi pas à paris d'imaginaire
collab là le look d'enfer et le cirque
bidon dans les rues de paris avec les
chevaux les rucks ce serait super mais
peut-être ça sera l'année prochaine ou
dans deux ans
beaucoup